hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 15 titled worth and Eugene
proved that it's definitely worth
scarfing down anchovy mac and cheese if
it can be weaponized as projectile vomit
blah critical hit now I'll get to
Eugene's puke attack and a bunch of
other details that you might have missed
this episode but let us start with the
big question posed by negan in the final
minutes
what is negan's planned for Dwight now
that the cats out of the bag when it
comes to Dwight playing both sides
why is naked even keeping him alive okay
first let's look at negan's plan during
this episode because it turns out that
the guy is a true technical genius this
episode confirmed our prediction last
episode that it was indeed Laura that he
picked up on the side of the road and
she got a bit of Sun but uh yeah that's
that's her so after returning with Laura
to the sanctuary negan knew that both
his top lieutenants Simon and Dwight had
betrayed him he learned from Jada said
Simon executed all the garbage people
against his wishes and he learned from
Laura that Dwight had been helping Rick
but negan doles out his punishment
slowly in true art of war fashion he
plays his enemies against each other
using Dwight to set up a mutiny
gathering to catch Simon and using
Dwight to disseminate false battle plans
through Gregory to Rick and Maggie then
and only then does pull the rug out from
under Dwight notice how when he first
reveals his return to Dwight he uses him
to help him roll a dumpster into
position Meighan was setting up his
hiding place for the later mutiny powwow
so that he could eavesdrop on and
surprise Simon so that explains why
negan kept Dwight alive this episode but
when he says Oh Dwight oh boy I got
plans for you what is he referring to
well it wouldn't make sense for negan to
try to imprison and torture Dwight into
loyalty again
Dwight's grudge against negan was just
too strong and Rick and the others don't
really care enough about Dwight for
negan to use them as like a hostage or
even a symbolic kill to intimidate them
yeah Dwight it's kind of screwed
I suppose negan could use Dwight to
further lure in Rick and the others into
false confidence like maybe four-seam
Dwight
radio them and declare that negan is
dead and that he's in charge now after a
successful mutiny
after which negan could just pop out and
declare surprise [ __ ]
it's also possible negan has plans for
Dwight after this war is won in his eyes
like maybe he plans to use Dwight to
manage a forced labor colony for the
civilians of the losing side either way
it's clear negan does not intend to kill
Dwight at least not yet he would have
done it already for sure he should have
done it already
for sure and there's only so many ways
to make an example out of someone after
burning his face with an iron and
bashing other scapegoats his brains in
with a bat and all in a world where
people literally get eaten alive okay
let's move on to the ways this episode
connected to past episodes in our
segment callbacks Chandler Riggs returns
this episode in a voiceover form as Rick
reads Carl's letter it's a super
sentimental moment filled with memories
of pizza Fridays and walks with dad and
Carl singles out a specific phrase the
bigger world that you used to talk about
he's referring to Alexandria in season
six when Carl got shot in the eye and
Rick after a miraculously clearing the
Walker horde and getting the vision of
the future said I want to show you a new
world girl that world as Rick described
it was a feeling that he hadn't felt
since before waking up from his coma and
it's precisely that pre zombie world
that Carl is a voguing in his letter
meanwhile when Simon and Gregory meet
early in the episode notice that they're
drinking a bottle of tequila this is a
callback to their little chat at the end
of last season where Simon offered to
quote crack open some tequila
we'll talk later negan confirms another
theory some of you have brought up
telling Simon what you did killing all
those men and all those boys and that
settlement yeah
negan is referring to Oceanside where
the women told Tara last season that all
the men and even younger boys were
sadistically executed by the Savior's at
the time we assume this was negan and
now we know it was actually Simon's
doing more and more were learning that
the most savage parts of the Savior's
reputation actually came from Simon all
this time they were
led by a moderate who prefers theatrics
and symbolic scapegoat killings and this
conflict between the two men echoes many
past AlphaDog showdowns and past seasons
of the show
negan makes Simon kneel to show
contrition similar to how Simon made
Gregory kneel at the hilltop in season
seven their fight to the death
reflects the fight between Rick and
Shane in season two with Shane as the
more extreme second-in-command who loses
the challenge like Simon here Shane was
an audience favorite who died in the
penultimate episode of the season the
same goes for Merle to the governor who
died in the penultimate episode of
season three once again by the top dog
himself later the governor killed Pete
his second-in-command who tried to take
over Woodbury in his absence the way
Simon did to negan and the governor
responded the same way Meighan does
strangling that guy to death now let's
move on from these past callbacks to
some interesting visual choices made in
this episode so let's lean in look
closely at these shots in our segment
zoom and enhance okay let's look closely
at Eugene this episode right before he
upchucks all that anchovy mac and cheese
on Rosita we get this close-up of his
fingers that he triggers his gag reflex
with Eugene's whole function this season
has been to manufacture bullets for
negan and even though he's unarmed here
he makes this little finger gun to
literally turn himself into a weapon
after chomping on Dwight's dick and
puking on Rosita
Eugene's most dangerous weapon is
definitely his mouth Eugene also makes
an interesting visual transformation
that's episode and past breakdowns I
described how Eugene's wardrobe changed
into dark apparel and how that reflects
his characters turn to the dark side
this episode he reverts back to his
cowardly pushed around state when Rosita
and Daryl kidnap him and his clothes
reflect that shift lighter tones
Rosita's insult that he do something
with his worthless life pisses him off
so when he pukes escapes he hides by
bury himself in a pile of dark ashes
that ash darkens his clothes reflecting
his dark turn back to being
true negan loyalist by the way when
Eugene talks to Gabriel this episode he
orders him to keep his mask on because
he isn't sure if Gabriel has influenza
or Cryptococcus that's a big word
Cryptococcus is a fungus that's in the
soil and it can go airborne to cause
meningitis
a disease that attacks the nervous
system and causes blurred vision or in
Gabriel's case booty hole vision so
Eugene is explaining that Gabriel's
illness might not be from inhaling
Walker guts but a simple fungus now I
don't know why the biology of how
diseases are spread on this show has to
be so confusing
let's also zoom and enhance on the map
that negan passes on to Dwight which
Dwight passes off to Rick through
Gregory Dwight says that each of the
circles represents a team of eleven
Savior's suggesting that negan has
upwards of a hundred and ten Savior's in
his army that's a lot even with a
possible back up from the Oceanside it
sounds like Rick is outgunned when it
comes to man to man then again this map
was fake Intel released intentionally by
negan so who knows how many many really
has good maps also if you look even more
closely at that map you can see the real
world location that the show used to
establish the hilltop Culpepper Virginia
that's about an hour hour and a half
drive from Alexandria now the last
visual detail I want to point out is the
close-up of Dwight's cigarette that
negan forces him to stomp out in the
past breakdown I pointed out how this
close-up of a cigarette being stomped
out could be a nod to the Shawshank
Redemption when the warden stomped it
out to act as a signal to the sniper to
take out the guy who's playing nice with
both Shawshank and Walking Dead Season
one were directed by Frank Darabont now
that could be the case here since negan
is definitely deceiving Dwight in a
similar way but really the cigarette is
a symbol of Dwight's connection to
Sherry his wife the two of them used to
share smokes and white continues to use
them as a reflection of his sadness of
her losing Sherri and his ongoing grudge
against negan for cuckolding he again
musta caught on to that because he
forces Dwight here to stomp out that
grudge the closing image of the episode
is a direct call back to this moment
with negan stomping out his radio at
token of his empathy toward his enemies
and his grief of her Carl's death just
as he tried to force Dwight to move on
from his loss Meighan is forcing himself
to move on from his loss and that brings
us to the deeper meaning of this episode
titled worth the title word comes from
Carl's letter to Rick at the top of the
episode in which she wrote you can make
it so that it never happens again
that we don't have to live this way that
every life is worth something to which
Rick responded shoot I wish I didn't
forget how to read ah now as Rick and
negan charge toward their final
collision in next week's finale this
penultimate episode served to remind us
of the theme of this season that all
life has value that vengeful killing
doesn't solve anything if it robs you of
your humanity and we'll see if the
boring man can ever learn this lesson
and finally see the worth of each other
and let's check in on this episode's
killcount finally negan has the most
blood on his hands he had those 13
mutinous saviors shot and killed
including Gary remember Gary yeah he's
gone now and yeah one of the saddest
losses of the season Simon guys I'm
really gonna miss Stephen OGG on this
show he brought charm and devilishness
to his performance that the show was
definitely missing when they didn't want
to pay Jeffrey Dean Morgan to appear in
an episode now you may have noticed how
Simon's Walker seemed more animated than
most smokers are augs said that he was
channeling a pit bull classic Simon even
his walkers are inspired a question for
you guys in honor of Simon a man we now
know Mass murdered two communities the
scavengers and also all the men and boys
of Oceanside who do you think is the
most evil character of The Walking Dead
Simon's definitely up there for me
treachery definitely Thompson negan's I
mean [ __ ] talks a big game but his
actions make him look like a saint next
to Simon of course there's also those
old bastard's that governor Merle Gareth
from terminus Joe or his pedo buddy Dan
or let's be honest Rick
Morgan Daryl they're all morally
bankrupt jerks when you think about it
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly at EA Boston follow
new rock stars on Twitter for
it's in our videos like this video share
it around subscribe to the new rock
stars for all of our Walking Dead deep
dives and be sure to watch my breakdowns
of past episodes for everything you
missed from those and I'll see you guys
next week for the season finale thanks
for watching bye